ABOUT CRUMBS, PER AGENT OR
OBSESSION WITH RUSSIA.
DON'T MISS THAT.
BUT FIRST, THE REAL SUMMIT
EMBARRASSMENT.
MEDIA REACTION TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CANCELING THE
NORTH KOREAN SUMMIT MIRRORED THE
REACTION TO THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF
THE SUMMIT.
IT WAS SCORN AND DERISION.
TO THEM, A LOSS FOR THE
PRESIDENT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
A SUCCESS FOR AMERICA, OR EVEN
FOR WORLD PEACE.
BACK ON MARCH 8TH, WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRST DELIVERED
NEWS OF THE SUMMIT, THE LEFT AND
THE MEDIA WERE IN SHOCK.
HOW COULD TRUMP OF ALL PEOPLE
SUDDENLY HAVE A SHOT AT FORGING
PEACE WITH THIS COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP?
MAYBE EVEN FORCE IT TO THE
NUCLEAR RISE, WHEREAS ARE     AL
NUCLEAR RISE, WHEREAS ARE     AT
NUCLEAR RISE, WHEREAS ARE     AE
OTHER PRESIDENTS HAD FAILED.
AFTERWARDS WITH LITTLE ROCKET
MAN, THE SUDDEN PROSPECT OF
PEACE WAS FRANKLY JUST MORE THAN
THEY COULD STAND.
AND SOMEHOW THEY SAID IT WAS
DANGEROUS.
>> OUR DEPARTMENT, THE CLOSEST
ALLIES, I'M SURE NOBODY ON THE
HILL KNEW ABOUT THIS.
DONALD TRUMP JUST DECIDED THIS
WAS THE REALITY TV SHOW
PRESIDENT TO CHANGE THE
HEADLINES.
AND, AND THAT HAS BEEN THE DREAM
OF NORTH KOREAN LEADERS FOR
DECADES NOW THAT THEY WOULD
ADVANCED THEIR NUCLEAR PROGRAMS
AND I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDED TO BE BE
THAT KIND OF A GIFT.
AND DONALD TRUMP AGREED,
KIM JONG UN IS LIKE QUOTE
RICHARD NIXON GOING TO CHINA,
BUT IF NIXON WERE A MORON."
WELL, SPEAKING OF MORONS COME UP
THIS CROWD AND THE PROSPECT OF A
SUMMIT TO THEM WAS NOT ONLY
DANGEROUS, BUT THE PRESIDENT WAS
A FOOL FOR ENGAGING THE
NORTH KOREANS AT ALL.
NOW THEY ARE SHIFTING NARRATIVES
AGAIN.
THE SAME CHAIN OF FOOLS IS
SAYING THE CANCELLATION IS
REALLY PERILOUS ITSELF AND
TRUMPS IMPETUOUS DIPLOMACY AND
INEXPERIENCE OF COURSE ARE AT
FAULT.
THE HEADLINE ON
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SCREAMED,
TRUMP IMPULSIVELY BLOWS UP THE
NORTH KOREAN SUMMIT.
THE EDITORIAL BOARD BLAMES TRUMP
FOR WHAT IT CALLED A HASTY
STRATEGY OF IMPROVISATION THAT
CHARACTERIZED HANDLING OF THE
DIPLOMATIC OPENING ALL ALONE.
ALONG.
THE POSTER BOARD, HAS SUCH CHAOS
AFFECTED THE MATTER OF SUCH
GRAVITY.
AND HERE IS HOW THE CABLE NEWS
NETWORK'S REACTIVE.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS RAISED
EXPECTATIONS TO THE POINT WHERE,
I'M IN CHARGE HERE.
IT WAS A LITTLE UNREALISTIC.
SPEAK OUT THE ART OF DIPLOMACY
IS HARDER THAN THE ART OF THE
DEAL.
>> DOES THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE
A LONG-TERM GAME PLAN HERE?
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SECRETLY RELIEVED.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S A SECRET,
I THINK THERE'S LOTS OF RELIEF.
>> LET'S GO TO PETER ALEXANDER
WHO IS LIVE AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
PETER, THIS IS A HUGE A WHILE
FOR US.
>> Laura: DID YOU CATCH THAT?
AT LEAST SHE'S IMPLICITLY SAYING
THAT MEDIA DID NOT INSIST ON
REPORTING FOR TRUMP BUT TO REVEL
IN HIS MISS PERCEIVED MISSTEPS.
THESE PEOPLE HAVEN'T BEEN THIS
HAPPY SINCE THEY THOUGHT OPRAH
WOULD RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE THRILLED TODAY.
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS I
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS F
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS H
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS O
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS S
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS A
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS D
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS I
WELL, TRUMPED         TRUMP IS F
HE DOESN'T.
POPE MIGHT I OFFER ANOTHER
POSSIBILITY HERE?
TRUMP'S RETREAT FROM THE SUMMIT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A GRAND
NEGOTIATING TACTIC, NOT AN
ADMISSION OF FAILURE AT ALL.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A WAY OF
TESTING KIM'S SERIOUSNESS AND
SQUEEZING MAY BE A FEW MORE
CONCESSIONS FROM HIM.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY GOTTEN
LITTLE ROCKET MAN TO HAND OVER
AMERICAN HOSTAGES AND THEY HAVE
ALLEGEDLY DETONATED THAT NUCLEAR
TESTING FACILITY, ALTHOUGH THAT
HE NOT BE AS BIG OF A STORY AS
WE HAD HOPED.
THE AP IS REPORTING THAT THE
NORTH ALLOWED THE NATIONAL
INSPECTORS TO MONITOR THE
SUPPOSED IMPLOSION.
BUT THIS WAS PART OF THE REASON
WHY TRUMP BACKED AWAY FROM THE
SUMMIT TABLE.
THE NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR HAD
ALSO BRISTLED AT THE TALK OF
DENUCLEARIZING HIS COUNTRY AND
THAT IS NONNEGOTIABLE FOR TRUMP.
WE ALSO LEARNED THAT
NORTH KOREAN OFFICIALS NEVER
SHOWED UP FOR PRELIMINARY TALKS
IN SINGAPORE LAST WEEK, WHICH
WAS A SURPRISE.
BUT IF HE READ THE PRESIDENT'S
LETTER TODAY, HE CLEARLY LEFT
THE DOOR OPEN TO A PEACE DEAL
AND TOLD KIM, IF YOU CHANGE YOUR
MIND HAVING TO DO WITH THIS
IMPORTANT SUMMIT, PLEASE DON'T
HESITATE TO CALL ME OR WRITE,
LIKE A PEN PAL.
BUT BY PULLING THE PLUG ON THE
SUMMIT THE PRESIDENT MAY WELL
HAVE APPLIED THE NEEDED
PRESSURE, AND THAT TOUGH STANCE
ALONG WITH CONTINUED ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS AND DIPLOMATIC
ISOLATION MAY ULTIMATELY
CONVINCE KIM JONG UN TO ACTUALLY
MAKE A SERIOUS DEAL.
THERE ARE NO NOW SIGNS THAT THE
TRUMP STRATEGY COULD BE WORKING.
NORTH KOREA'S VICE FOREIGN
MINISTER IN A STATEMENT TONIGHT
SAYS, OUR GOAL AND WILL TO DO
EVERYTHING FOR PEACE AND
STABILITY OF THE GRAN PENINSULA
AND MANKIND REMAINS UNCHANGED.
WE ARE ALWAYS WILLING TO GIVE
TIME AND OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE
WITH AN OPEN MIND.
THERE IS AN INTENTION TO SIT AND
RESOLVE ANY AND ALL ISSUES.
OF COURSE IT'S, THE
NORTH KOREANS ARE STILL RULING
OUT TOTAL DENUCLEARIZATION.
MY TAKE?
LET THE MEDIA CHAIR WITH THE
HOPE IS ANOTHER TRUMP SETBACK.
LET THEM RALLY AGAINST PEACE AND
AGAINST AMERICAN LEADERSHIP IN
THE WORLD.
BEHIND THE SCENES, TRUMP MAY
PULL OFF A PEACE DEAL YET, AND